Hey there friends. So the name of the
game today is piouetses. Namely these
poi dance moves that I love to do that
involve turning my body around in a
complete circle like so. And the thing
is I have a lot of different tricks that
I like to team up with those piouettes.
So what are some of my favorites? Well
stay tuned to find out.
Drex here from Drex Factor PO sharing
with you the love of PO spinning and
flow arts to benefit your body and
brain. And today the order of business
is playing around with po tricks that
make a good fit for piouettes. But
before we dive in, I just want to give a
quick shout out to the friends of the
channel. Big thanks to Dark Monk, Fire
Mecca, Flowfests, Flow Toys, Parot Light
Toys, and Ultraoy for helping to make
the videos on this channel possible. You
can learn more about all these awesome
companies and the work they're doing to
support flow artists like yourself by
checking out the links down in the
description of this video. And special
thanks to the non-b businessiness friend
of the channel, Pekka Becklanin. Thank
you so very much for supporting my
channel, my work, and my mission. All
right. So, first order of business here.
What do I mean when I refer to a
pyouette? Well, a pyouette is a dance
move wherein you turn around in a circle
and you go up on one foot up on your
tippy toes and the other foot uh gets
involved in helping out with the turn
somehow. The lingo for this is that you
have what's called the standing leg,
that is the one that's still connected
to the ground, and you have the working
leg. That is the one that is helping you
go up and around. There are two flavors
of piouetses namely those in which you
are turning in the direction of the
working leg which are referred to as
indors or you have those where you are
turning in the direction of the standing
leg which is also referred to as
indidons. Now please note I am terrible
at French and I think it is just going
to be better for our purposes if I refer
to these by the translated names for
them. So if you are turning in the
direction of the working leg, it is an
outside piouette. And when you are
turning in the direction of the standing
leg, it is an inside piouette. Make
sense? And if this is all great to you
and you need a guide on how to do
piouetses in the first place, stay tuned
to the end of the video and I will point
you to a tutorial that will help you
out. But for right now, let's talk five
tricks that are a great fit for
piouettes. Trick number one, the
Frankenstein.
So, the Frankenstein has the distinction
of being the first poet trick that I
think I ever used in conjunction with a
piouette. And that's because in simplest
terms, it was just the easiest way that
I could make the two things work
together. I call it the Frankenstein
because really, I'm just letting the po
stick out from either side of my neck
like the bolts in Frankenstein's neck. I
have to bring my hands up real close to
my throat in order to make this happen.
But that also helps out because it means
that I am doing this turn from a place
where I am conserving angular momentum
and that's helping me get around which
like to be clear if you just practice
doing that inside pyouette by itself.
All you need to do to get it into that
Frankenstein territory is just let the
poi out and then kind of automatically
the Frankenstein happens. All we do is
just keep our hands close to us. Right?
It should also be said you can do this
from a place where say you perform a
stall out to each side or you know you
could do it from a place where you're
performing pendulums to each side as
well. Your choice. All right. So the
Frankenstein's a great place to start,
but I think it's a little vanilla. So
how about we get a little bit more po
movement involved in these piouettes?
Yeah. Trick number two, horizontal
flowers.
So, I'm going to say horizontal flowers
are probably one of the best candidates
for a trick that is just a natural fit
for doing pureetses. Not just because it
keeps that motion in a horizontal plane,
but also too because it adds just a
little bit more interest with the
movement of the PO as well. This is also
the first trick we've seen on this list
that I would argue works equally well as
an inside or an outside powette. From
both of these positions, you can pretty
easily get up and around with the flower
petals. It's just a question of which
leg you want to have as your working
leg. So, let's take a look at both
cases. Number one, if I'm going to do
the outside piouette, I'm probably going
to start with a jazz prep here. That
means that I'm going to be down in pa
with uh what is going to turn out to be
my standing leg slightly forward and my
working leg slightly back. The uh hand
attached to the working leg side is
going to be sticking straight out in
front of me. And the hand attached to
the standing leg side is going to be out
to the side. From here, I can do my PA
come up. And what do you know about
that? It's just a matter of spinning the
PO around as I turn in place. I think it
looks pretty cool. And of course, you
can decide whether you're going to have
those pedals be above your hands or
whether you're going to have those
pedals be below your hands, depending
upon what you're looking to do with this
and the effect you want to get. When it
comes to doing the inside pyouette, I
would probably start with the opposite
stance where I've got my standing leg
forward and my working leg back. And
from here, I can just go ahead and once
again do my pa and come up with my right
foot if I'm going to be turning to the
left and bring my poi either above my
hands or keeping them below my hands
depending upon what effect I'm
specifically looking to do here. You'll
also note that as I'm doing this, I'm
keeping my poi short. You don't have to.
I just find that it makes the turns a
little bit easier. You can also just as
easily leave your PO full length. That
will actually give you a little bit more
time going through the turn if you want
to kind of trick it out a little bit.
But do bear in mind this means that you
are going to need to have more control
so you can keep yourself up in the
pyouette for a little bit longer. All
right, so we've explored two different
horizontal plane moves when it comes to
our pyouetses. Now let's move on to some
vertical plane ones.
Trick number three,
extensions. Ah, extensions. The power of
them lies in their simplicity and thus
their flexibility. Because there's so
little going on with the poi, it leaves
a lot of room for us to do things with
our bodies. And of course, important
question when it comes to our
extensions. What timing and direction
mode do we want to be in as we're
performing these piouettes? Well, I'm
going to be real with you. The answer is
yes. Piouettes are an appropriate fit
for literally any timing and direction
mode. You can do any of them and still
make a piouette work. This is again one
of those cases where we're probably
going to want to do our inside
pureetses. It is possible to do these
with outside piouettes, although I would
argue it is just a little bit trickier
to get there. But to do the inside
version, we're basically going to be
starting off say if you're going to do
together same, you're going to be
sweeping both of your hands and pi down
and around as you're picking up your
working leg. and that will carry you all
the way through the turn. When it comes
to together opposites, on the other
hand, you want to use the momentum of
both of the poi going up to carry your
entire body up and that will carry you
around through the turn as well. One
thing to watch out for here is to make
sure that each of your hands is reaching
around as far as they can as you're
performing the turn. The reason being
that now you're working in a place where
one of the hands is working against the
direction of momentum of your turn. So,
make sure that you're keeping your
forces balanced here. Otherwise, you're
going to have a really difficult time
getting through the turn. Same thing for
split time opposites. You want to make
sure you're putting plenty of momentum
into both poi as you take them around.
Otherwise, you're going to find that
you're going to get stuck in some spot.
And please note that as you're doing the
turn, you're going midway through the
turn, as the PO are sliding past each
other over to the side. Your body kind
of slips between the two planes. That's
what makes this one work. And of course,
the fun one, split time, same direction.
Basically, you know that trick that we
sometimes use in both crossers as well
as watermills where we focus on which po
we're following through the turn. You
pick just one po and that winds up being
your leader the entire way through. So
with my left po here, I'm going to
follow it down, up, and down to get
through my piouette. Or I can follow the
right one going down, up, down if I want
to go the other way. This is one of
those places where you can get in in
outside pureet if you want to, but you
kind of have to orient yourself against
the poi rather than with it. So, as I go
down with my right hand here, I'm going
to be pulling back with my right
foot. It works, just takes a little bit
of work to get there. All right, so are
we ready to add just a little bit of
complexity to the poi?
Excellent. Trick number four, anti- spin
flowers.
So yeah, I'm willing to bet that this is
the one that many of you out there have
been waiting for. And has to be said
that when it comes to po moves that are
absolute classics when combined together
with piouettes, anti-pin flowers are
really high on the list. And just like
our old friend the extensions, anti-
spin flowers will work with piouettes in
any timing and direction mode. Kind of.
Personally, I think that the ones in
together same are a little bit
challenging to combine with piouettes
just because they take so long to get
around and the momentum of the po is
working against the momentum of the
hands. But pretty much any other timing
and direction mode should be a good fit
here. Okay, so now that we are dealing
in anti-pin flowers, it does have to be
said that the big challenge is no longer
making the piouette happen every time,
but rather how to turn back and forth
between the anti-pin flowers facing
downstage as well as upstage. Because as
we're going around here, we have to swap
between these different planes in order
to make the turning with the anti-pin
flowers work. So, how do we do that? So,
I've seen a variety of different ways
that people tackle this particular
challenge. And this is my personal
approach. Just know that there are
others out there, but this is the one
that I find works for me. So,
essentially what we're going to do is
we're going to be swapping uh planes
between the hands kind of on the fly.
Let me show you. So, for me, this starts
off with my left hand high and my right
hand low. Uh, I'm spinning my PO
clockwise here. My hands are going to go
around counterclockwise. And my first
move is to go from top and bottom to out
to the side. Now, as soon as I hit the
side pedal, I'm swapping my left hand to
the plane behind me. Now, that left hand
is going to continue down while the
right hand goes up. As the right hand
goes up, I'm switching to the plane
behind me now. So now I have both of the
poi spinning what looks like
counterclockwise relative to me back
here facing upstage. And I'm going to
bring my left hand out to stage right
and my right hand out to stage left. And
when that happens, boom. Once again, I'm
going to switch my left hand to uh
performing its spinning behind me while
my right hand is still on this upstage
plane. And then when my left hand goes
up and my right hand goes down, boom.
That's when I switch both poi into that
downstage plane. So let me show you what
that looks like from the side here.
Again, I start left hand high, right
hand low. And as they come down to the
sides, boom. As I'm entering into the
pedal on my left hand side here, my left
hand is going to do a little tic tac to
bring it to the plane behind me. Then as
my left hand goes down and my right hand
goes up at the tip of the top pedal, I
switch my right hand PO plane around to
being on the same side as my left hand
PO plane. Now, as they go out to the
sides, I once again switch my left hand
plane before the right hand plane. And
as the left goes up and the right goes
down, boom, that's when they both arrive
in the same plane here. So, it's left
shifts, right shifts, left shifts, right
shifts as I go around here. Check it out
in slow motion.
So the only step that's really left
there to do is to get the feet involved
and take it around either in an outside
piouette or in an inside pyouette. I
almost always choose to do the inside
piouette, but that one is up to you
friends. And in case you're wondering,
this same system works exactly the same
way in both together opposite as well as
split time opposite. Namely that I go
ahead and switch the plane with one hand
and then the other. Switch the plane
with one hand and then the other. And
that will take me through the turn. As
you can see, this also works in split
time opposite. Switch one and then the
other and bring it back around like so.
All right. So, we have covered the
Frankenstein. We've covered horizontal
flowers. We've covered vertical flowers
and extensions. So, what could there be
left for us to explore here? H trick
number five, spiral
wraps. Hey, now we're cooking with gas.
This one looks very unique and it poses
some very interesting challenges too. So
the whole theory behind this is that you
are performing the pyouette in the
opposite direction that the poi is
spinning in such that your momentum as
you're going through the turn is going
to cause the poi to perform a spiral
wrap above your head and then
automatically come back out of it. And
I'll be the first to admit that this one
is really counterintuitive and kind of
difficult to get down. In fact, I had to
do a bunch of takes to get that little
bit of B-roll that I just showed you in
slow motion. But here are some best
practices. So, first and foremost, I'm
going to decide which way I'm going to
turn, I'm going to say that I'm going to
start by turning to my right. So, that
means that as I look down at me from
above, I'm going to be turning around
clockwise. And that means as I look
down, I'm going to need to start with my
PO spinning counterclockwise. Uh, I'm
going to do this as an inside pyouette
simply because I'm slightly more
comfortable with inside piouettes. But
essentially what I'm going to look to do
is bring the poi up and perform the
spiral wrap as I'm turning through my
upstage side here and then they can come
back out. Now counterintuitively, if you
want to just do these back to back, you
actually have to continue the motion
coming out of the last spiral wrap. So
now I have the poi spinning clockwise as
I look down in them from above. And if I
want to perform that spiral wrap again,
I have to go around to my left
counterclockwise. But hey, not that big
a deal. I can perform a beat and go down
and back up. A beat down and go back up.
Beat down, go back up, beat down, go
back up. Like so. In all of these cases,
the momentum of the poi doesn't matter
so much because as you're closing in on
the kind of nexus point of the spiral
wrap, um the poi for all intents and
purposes are barely spinning anymore.
It's that moment when they come together
and you keep going that is going to add
momentum to it. And that is the moment
you need to watch out for and make sure
that you've got enough momentum going
into your uh pyouette to be able to
continue all the way through even with
the poi robbing some of your momentum at
that very key point. And of course,
obvious question, isn't it possible to
do a spiral wrap in the same direction
that you're turning in? Well, I mean,
technically so, but you're going to find
that you're going to have a very, very
difficult time getting back out of it.
Part of what makes it work to turn in
the opposite direction that the poyer's
spinning in is that it gets you into the
spiral wrap much much sooner. If I go in
the same direction as a spiral wrap, I'm
not going to be able to get to the nexus
point until the turn is completely
finished. So when I go in the opposite
direction like so, it ensures that I am
out of the spiral wrap by the time I
come out of the turn. Awesome. So, those
were my picks for five po tricks that go
excellently with piouettes. Which one
was your favorite? And did I leave a
favorite off of the list? Let me know
down in the comments. Be sure to like,
share, comment, and subscribe to help
other people find this video and of
course to help my channel grow.
This video and all the videos on this
channel would not be possible without my
amazing supporters on Patreon. In
particular, I'd love to give a shout out
to my flow patrons who are listed on
screen right now. Thank you all so much.
You rock. And if you out there watching
would like to support the channel, I can
offer you three awesome ways to do that.
Number one, if you'd like to get your
name in the credits or access to a whole
host of other awesome rewards, please
check out my Patreon over at
patreon.com/drexrexfactorpo and sign up.
If on the other hand, you would prefer
to just do a one-off donation, you don't
want to sign up for a subscription
service, I totally get it. You can send
me a donation via either PayPal or
Venmo. I am at Drexfactor on both
platforms, and I will include links to
do that down in the description. Thanks
in advance. And hey, have you been
hanging on this whole video to learn how
to do your pureetses cuz I promised it
up front? Well, now I got you. I'm going
to put up on screen a tutorial that I
did several years ago on how to begin to
get down your piouetses so you can start
putting them together with tricks like
these. Awesome. Thanks so much for
watching. Make sure you get out and flow
today and I'll see you with a new video
real soon. Take care now. Peace.